la expresidenta parc un ha salido airosa
indultada tras una condena de 20 años de
cárcel por varios delitos de corrupción
el viernes el ministro de justicia
anunció que la decisión se había tomado
en base a la salud de la ex mandataria y
para lograr en la unidad nacional powell
hemos incluido a la ex presidenta para
kun y al ex primer ministro jan yang
sook en la lista de indultos para
superar una historia desafortunada
propiciar la unidad para superar el cob
y 19 y la crisis para nacional y ofrecer
una oportunidad para dar un nuevo paso
hacia el futuro que depongan wa
champions con mucho hundir el parqué del
ala conservadora se convirtió en la
primera mujer presidenta de corea del
sur en 2012 su llegada al poder fue muy
celebrada algo que no la libró de su
caída en desgracia en 2017 cuando fue
declarada culpable de abuso de poder y
de aceptar millones de dólares en
sobornos de conglomerados del país como
samsung en enero de 2020 pasó a ser
elegible para un indulto en ese momento
su sucesor liberal y actual presidente
mundial y no dijo que no era apropiado
hablar de su amnistía la decisión de
concederle la libertad marca un cambio
en su política a pocas semanas de dejar
el cargo y tres meses antes de las
próximas elecciones